the wagons have some fun you know people
always ask me why like intelligence what
does that have to do with being the best
is there any synchronicity between hobby
of TV the guy's got a shock peg find
another stream to work Discovery Channel
knows well what's enough to it making
money let me walk you're just the way I
tell me because it's over maybe why he
said so if you know this woman Madeline
I've been working with her for nine
years now she's the most attractive
congressman some of you may remember
pierre trudeau her father was in
Pierre's actual cap was otto lay-ins
minister very famous local family she's
very intelligent i like to say about the
show i can never do it with hang because
if i'm not there one hundred percent
there is your spot really that's why
it's great television now it's just
about the shoulders I've just finished
it about 18 minutes ago today we had
five guests now what is every economist
every CEO every author every artist
every politician every hedge fund
manager pension fund manager the private
equity guy what do they all want they
all want to be on television every
single one now if you're an investor
howdy try to get access to these people
you tell you the rules of TV waiting
back in the days of Johnny Carson was a
very eclectic common human show you made
our rule you stood by this guest and
green when you go on TV before you could
get on the camera start on my face right
now yes but it's powder on the skin the
same you're not even wear when you're
dead that stops the shine of your skin
takes about 18 minutes is how much real
estate out in your head in the green
room is two chairs on mega parsec two
chairs in the days of Johnny Carson used
to invite his yes in saleable are
putting on your makeup just you
understand the way I've got our
ingredients whatever we talk about will
never fall in here it's off Rebecca this
is something started years and years ago
in the 60s when Ted Turner set up CNN he
made the same rules well told everybody
that came into the green room whenever
we talk about the great rooms off the
record so if you're in the television
business some of you probably aspire to
be here one day this is a role that is
accepted all around the world whatever
is discussed in the green is off the
record let's get back it's going show
honor show tonight was an economist and
a CEO security country very interesting
sectors for me so knowing that they were
going to be on the air I got there 18
minutes early on the way to the makeup
room and a set there what we're going to
make that one you talk can you have
management information flow over the
years that I get getting access ladder
Prime Minister every CEO who's ever
running all the pension plans I never
get to its people ever if it was
intelligent Gotham to myself 18s every
single day and everybody knows where we
talk about is off the record let me give
an example some of you may not area
hockey I'm hurt why what's remarkable
about this woman three years ago with a
thousand dollars instead of having to
post online it now challenges the new
york times for ad dollars that's the
institutions over 100 years old she's
getting the same ad rates on early most
which is incredible so she's a lot to do
with it was disrupted on the internet
here she is coming up to the CC
interviewed and we decided do it wrong
and you can see it here is the makeup
artist find that they have on my head
now this is
in the green room she knows the deal and
I say the real estate I Rihanna to get
buying some Tribune ultimate big launch
like the black ones they just came a
bank receiving sponsor illegal f %
assumed in the market today is that
every quarter every 90 days ad revenue
print goes down five percent so immense
even companies deal will pay back those
bonds something you can calculate just
using a spreadsheet so I say her look
I'm thinking investing a lot of money
Richard coupons really like them she
said you know Kevin why would you have a
way to the forwards came up next week
advertising is a concept called forwards
where every 90 days they say how much
commitment because sold by how many
large companies at what price and
advertising I said what do you know area
that I would i know i SPECT feeling but
why don't you just wait before they make
this bond commitment to see how the
forward slope so i call it the trade
investment Boston say hold on bubbly
that's kind of I was long as yet
somebody please i'm a Boston Mass 35
million dollars a portfolio guests were
going all week I said no as some
ingested I want to make sure none four
days late for words come out it was not
a five percent attrition it was
seventeen percent of it lost that court
bonds collapsed obviously because the
propensity the companies are now selling
advertising pretty may not have enough
money to pay back loans 25 years because
it's an accelerating attrition to online
advertising I save a fortune from that
little interview and how could I ever
Bob to her or ever
had that conversation I wouldn't keep
doing till TV into like that there's no
business like show business and no
question about that so if you know this
show trying to talk about it he's been
part of this phenomenal success I don't
think even the CDC can fathom why this
thing is so successful this is a monster
nine year old girls a 90 year old band
watch this show we give you some metrics
the news piece of a senator than 85,000
people on weeknight watch international
hockey game he set up 1.2 billion if
it's not a playoff game that's a big
government can drag instead two and a
half in English that's huge now i have
my own theory why this is happening and
i think it's this it's one of the
reasons are you today watching the
process of dragons that are full is
watching people pursue the most noble
effort over that of freedom what is
financial free it's pure free that means
to you you'll never have to take that a
phone call you want that's what
financial agreements you have complete
control of your time you can do whatever
you want your life for so many of us you
have that is in all of your suit there's
nothing more noble than increasing
wealth and i think even a 9 pro girl
guess it watch pursuing these dreams
even though the probabilities are low
everybody else is trying to figure out
how can i come free what is it going to
take for me to make enough money that i
can completely remove the shadows
anymore on my life that's what the
pursuit of wealth is about and that's
what you're watching the dragon stick I
needs a powerful mystical force and
creates amazing television shows damn
glasses long and this thing keeps
growing here I think it's absolutely
wonderful I think it's a great level I
think Travis damage shark tank and give
a Shoshone talk about and we come the
American Idol venture capital I think
you can launch a business on this show
then you can take the product that's
unknown there's no distribution and get
a distribution to make a business up who
wouldn't want to do that I kind of doing
that over and over and if I can from the
success of drag instead as Mark
mentioned our content konami what an
interesting opportunity who wouldn't go
to Los Angeles
you have no idea how crazy that way
again let's take intelligence I got
phone may be seizing up Kevin why don't
you come down set up as a scars not only
dance really said no no you see the
front of the audience and when the
camera zooms in the [ __ ] you shadow
watch shark tank at nine o'clock right
after Desert it's cause I said I'm going
to fight all the way to LA to say that
the ten seconds no you're lying to get
David to that they said well look do it
will stitch besides somebody would
waiting to eat your whole life because
we know you're only company store I said
well okay come out got me interested who
is it some of you know who's the creator
about everybody knows steve jobs but you
remember wozny animals he was the
engineer he's they got never takes
meetings he's a legend semitech
investor's on earth really rich he has
Alice talking 15 sets of stones that's
your advice this guy is well known as a
genius nobody destiny I guess what loves
dancing with the stars on dancing with
the stars they sucked you lost by the
way because every single takes is in the
front row this is but if you do this for
us get you together with dinner with
watch the act and you do talk about what
you hold up to do investing
technology the grime and David in the
front row just before it happens there I
am with the woz after two telescopes
such as a dancer but who cares my
amazing guy he was absolutely fantastic
again Fievel television how could you
ever get near this guy doesn't want to
take it being with another investor is
singable that way past them and he's a
legend in the space i can notice offers
created the first habit he's an amazing
guy still a big player for my son didn't
care about was gone but love khansa
there's been a couple of minutes just
talking about its velocity I think you
need to be successful everybody has a
different opinion on this stuff so you
know you should know my politics i'm
slightly right of a total time so you
may not agree with everything I say
about only bringing forward to something
you free to consider because this is my
interpretation of what it takes to be
successful entrepreneur and I think
every element or that has had some
success and thing about businesses you
can measure success because you monetize
it in the end it's really the monarch
what you're doing is for you cannot
there's no grave business like a big
money or you lose money that's it so I
think everyone to know that says success
making money should go back to a next
generation say here's what I know here's
what I know you some space I made is
what I think works for me and then you
can pull from these ideas for yourself
because in this room statistically
there's going to be about 15 of you have
become very wealthy and about five of
you in a stinking rich
ones you are it's going to happen so I'm
question about and I hope you will do
well as well the stats are really
interesting no becoming a successful
entrepreneur require certain medicine
I'll tell you what I think they are so
I'm just going to keep this really
simple the recent must be failed
business is they make the assumption
that would it and they're egotistical
maniac and even when it starts to fail
because of their own inadequacies they
don't stop themselves and ago that's a
typical situation so you have to look
yourself in the mirror this is hard to
do sometimes and say what am I really
good at and what do I suck it because
you don't want to spend any of your time
doing things you're no good I'll give
you an example I hate logistics and
operations you're going to software
company have to make ten million dis a
month you don't like that you better
find a guy who knows how to do that and
you better make it your partner very
early on process and I mean part I mean
you give him something to give equity up
to fulfill the weaknesses in your own
portfolio that is the key success I have
never made any money doing on myself
ever so many businesses started many
failed at many the only ones I've really
made money on the harshest where I found
people that were good at things that I
wasn't good at I don't need employees
I'd be giving them action in the
business so that they have the same
risks and desires that I have there's
only two things in business that matter
one is opening its and the other is
being an employee guess which one you
want to be I just fired employee say
even costi month they all possible
rather have lesson
I did that because the rest of the
partners in the business have a clue I
wanna make the bridge on with me you
have to be dar waiting about this so you
need to own a piece of the business
community success that's for the
leverage is but the only way it works as
far as I'm concerned did you only focus
on your strengths and don't ever tell me
that you're good at everything because
you're lying to yourself there's no
question about it there's something else
you need and sometimes you can acquire
this teacher sometimes your pain I have
your own but it's something I think we
don't spend no time in business schools
everybody in this class should be forced
to come down here where I am right now
present their idea of aggressive their
classmates even though you think you
sick to do it or you're nervous I'm
always nervous going to resent to people
you have to get over it because
communication skills are probably the
most important thing you can have if
your business leader undoing have to be
able to get up in front of a ruby Slater
idea your vision how you're going to
make money jurors in ninety cents not to
be able communicate your vision and
articulated in a way that everybody can
understand you can't do that you better
start practicing it from the mirror that
it gets special coaching it really
really matters a lot in fact business
schools as far as I mean certain things
that number one naturally we should have
acutely the ability to stand up in front
of group of people when they have been
your employees or whether they end up
being investors and explain exactly what
your vision is this is absolutely
crucial
that you can the top of your list I
don't care to go to finance or an
operations or marketing what I care
about some investors can you lead people
can you communicate to them are you
avail be able to explain to me your
vision hence your employees but people
work for you if you're going to be
successful to marymount employees they
have to go to war with you every day
that's going to battle believe them it's
about it they have to trust you even
when you're wrong even when you doubt
your own decisions they can't see that
when you sink if the stand up and say
here's we're going to do today tomorrow
next month next year is the planet
here's why it's going to work and they
have to believe those are communication
skills have to have absolutely important
can't say enough about that and if
you're not learning them here tell your
professors to get on it and start
teaching at you because that's more
important than you guys laser focus i'm
cherylin returns what that means money
is the blood of business you always have
to respect the month number what that
means you have to fire your mother
firing both you have to keep your
business alive to keep the shareholder
value with you look risk their money to
give it to you that's all that matters
you know this idea of a balance balance
your life time for a family dog sister
and your school and your charity that's
all crap that's all I'm thinking crap
you start a business we're going to
spend 25 hours a day running that is
to live a diet you won't get Mary to get
rich that's why I like that there's no
time for anything else except the
business that's it if you want creative
it's going to because you you mean you
made money on the business can focus on
so hard that when you weren't looking in
BK th you love it so much you're so
passionate about it spend all of your
waking hours working on it wake up one
morning say [ __ ] I'm rich exactly how it
happens just pursue welcome to save
money lender which is because you're so
passionate people follow you into war
you create wealth but there's no balance
there's no balance ever there's no
balance what so it fits all crap it's a
winners so now the most of sacrifice
their lives success those the kind of
people are uncontested you don't you can
do that on every community if you don't
think you can do that you will not be
successful is anybody your doubt could
you become a slave to your business does
anybody even think that's not going to
be the case if it's the one thing you
think of this meeting tonight with me is
you will live and die business if it's
yours you will have no balance in your
life you may fail twice three times but
that's what it takes to be a complete
personal sacrifice get over it that's
what matters
but everybody I can some people say what
an [ __ ] I don't care I think it's the
most important element I'm serious when
I say this it's all about the money
that's it it's all depends you don't
make friends and business you make fun
that's what matters you cannot have a
conscience about this if you have to
fire your best friend like I did you got
to do it it was brutal but it had to be
done sometimes the people in breaking
with his initial if your relatives your
friends are not the ones that you need
to be successful you have to make those
tough decisions every single day over
and over and over and over again very
hard to do every time i sit down
somebody this work with you for years
who have terminated by today dinners but
I have to do it it's for the business
you know what I sleep very well no
problem no conscience no mercy just the
pursuit of welcome chefs that's all that
matters which i'm using a hardship think
about that well you need and then on
this topic here gave our fireside chat
next but listen the polling was once
asked what kind of generals do you like
i love is an specific i like lucky
chance
settings he said there's something about
whether that's part of the forward part
of their beef and you know when I eat
successful entrepreneurs or people that
they can be successful there's another
element I'm not sure where it comes from
but over the years I learned lot really
important and I think it's a comment I
don't know where husband but I will soon
entrepreneur there's three things that
have to have the ability to communicate
and articulate their vision in two
minutes so I again I understand what
they're trying to do that they can spend
maybe five minutes explains me why they
can execute on the business plan because
there's a difference between a great
business idea of an entrepreneur has an
ability to execute because when I form a
partnership a bunch of your usually I
take control so that applier that person
they can execute the plan I'll hire
somebody else they still remain show so
i'll make the bridge but i want the
buggy needs are out of business because
those are two different things but
sometimes it you see this is like
isotopes sizzling somebody standing in
front of just articulating their vision
and their ability to execute the plan
and then you see they have that or that
have that match those of the guys I
write a check for those are the way we
did they have that certain something I
don't know what it is maybe it's part of
your ability to project is your vision
for energy this is something that
investors see over and over again but
you can only see it when you're in the
presence of greatness sure some of you
have this room that is what makes
it'll leave you with a rather sobering
statistic because although you're going
to pursue realm of the world it's one
sharp and presentation on top and give
it over heels I run over a billion
dollars as an investor did you know that
unless box there are more billion dollar
market cap companies outside of north
america that units the first time ever
our great society we go this moment last
20 years has no longer the fastest
growing on earth there's more companies
making more money or faster so I'm North
America needed Brazil India China South
Korea Thailand Cambodia that is the
future project notes that is where the
action kids were wrong or old and fat
aging society everywhere else is on five
if I were you guys I get a leg over zoo
34 million people emerging middle class
they're wanting everything you already
have dying for if I were young and
starting again up to a year this place
is never going to grow at eight percent
you can be getting for lifetime all
those countries are think about that a
very interesting observation by the way
weather is good there lots of super
problems you have pretty interesting
society but I go there I really would I
just landed up Lane bigger Sean Kevin
let's give my hand